Considering it’s practically the biggest
movie franchise in history, it can be pretty
hard to keep track of what's going on in the
MCU—and what's coming up.
And while Marvel’s next phases are still
shrouded in secrecy, we do know a few of the
upcoming projects slated for release.
In early 2018, writer/director James Gunn
confirmed that the third installment of the
ridiculously successful Guardians of the Galaxy
franchise would be on its way in 2020, and
a few months later, he announced via Twitter
that a script had been completed.
But an unexpected turn of events threatened
to kill the film entirely: amid a kerfuffle
over some years-old, highly inappropriate
tweets made by Gunn, Disney decided to part
ways with the director.
It was heartbreaking news for fans, not to
mention the cast, who uniformly stood behind
Gunn in a joint public statement.
Eventually, it was reported that the House
of Mouse were to use Gunn's script, but would
not bring him back as director.
Luckily for Guardians fans everywhere, Disney
announced in March 2019 that Gunn would be
rejoining the Marvel universe after all, for
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3.
Unfortunately, the whole firing scandal means
the project’s release date — which was
originally set for 2020 — is now up in the
air, but that seems a small price to pay for
Gunn’s triumphant return to the director’s
chair.
"Boom!"
He may have been last seen crumbling to dust
in the arms of Tony Stark at the end of Avengers:
Infinity War, but the drama of that moment
was tempered slightly by the fact that we
all knew Tom Holland's Peter Parker would
be back to web-sling another day.
It was known well in advance of the character's
dusting that Holland would be appearing in
more than one Spidey solo film, and sure enough,
it was later confirmed that Spider-Man: Far
from Home would take place after the events
of Avengers: Endgame.
This sequel will see young Parker going on
a European excursion with his classmates — a
relaxing sojourn which turns not-so-relaxing
when Nick Fury and Maria Hill show up to enlist
him in the fight against a team of mysterious
elemental monsters.
Joining the cast is Jake Gyllenhaal as Mysterio,
a longtime Spider-Man nemesis in the comics
who — if the trailer is to be believed — is
actually fighting on the side of the good
guys... at first, at least.
But fans know that Mysterio is prone to whipping
up all manner of intricate illusions in support
of his criminal schemes, so there’s a good
chance there may be more to his relationship
to Spidey’s new foes than meets the eye.
Scarlett Johansson's Black Widow has popped
up in no fewer than six MCU films, and has
exactly the kind of shady past that would
be ripe for further exploration, should Marvel
choose to go that route.
And although a Black Widow solo flick has
been rumored for years, it has finally been
confirmed that we're actually going to get
one.
The film got the green light in mid-2018,
and Marvel has already begun filling out its
team.
Writer Jac Schaeffer was hired before the
project was even greenlit, and after meeting
with over 70 potential directors, the studio
finally settled on Australian filmmaker Cate
Shortland.
Shortland's filmography isn’t exactly extensive;
she's perhaps best known for 2012's Lore,
a little-seen but critically acclaimed historical
drama.
But if there's one thing we know about Marvel,
it's that their out-of-left-field directorial
choices nearly always turn out to be blindingly
brilliant in hindsight.
For now, fans can be assured that the project
is in good hands — and all they can reasonably
ask is that Schaeffer and Shortland clue us
in as to what really happened in Budapest.
"This is just like Budapest all over again."
"You and I remember Budapest very differently."
With 2016's Doctor Strange a smash hit and
the character playing such a crucial role
in the conflict with Thanos, it seemed like
a no-brainer that the Sorcerer Supreme would
play a major role in the MCU’s fourth phase.
An unconfirmed report citing an anonymous
source from the Mirror suggests that Benedict
Cumberbatch has received a huge pay bump to
star in the sequel, which may start shooting
as soon as 2019 — but whether or not this
is actually correct, the inevitability of
Doctor Strange 2 has been confirmed not only
by Cumberbatch, but by Kevin Feige as well.
When asked about continuing in the role by
Deadline, Cumberbatch didn't mince words.
He told the publication:
"Just try to stop me.
That's all kind of lined up as far as I'm
aware, but who knows?
I mean, you know, the problem is, how does
he get out of where he's at.
But that's the only thing."
And while doing press for Ant-Man and the
Wasp, Feige confirmed to CinemaBlend that
Doctor Strange 2 would be set a number of
years after the first.
In December 2018, Hollywood Reporter even
confirmed that Doctor Strange director Scott
Derrickson would return to helm the project
— but of course, we're not likely to get
many more details about Doctor Strange 2 until
after Phase Three is complete.
While a sequel based around the Sorcerer Supreme
hasn't been officially confirmed, Marvel isn't
playing nearly as coy about King T'Challa's
second solo outing.
It doesn't have an official title or release
date, but Black Panther 2 has been officially
confirmed by the studio — which isn’t
exactly a huge surprise, considering the original
became one of the highest-grossing films of
all time and Marvel's first film to receive
a Best Picture nomination at the Oscars.
Not only is the sequel officially happening,
but Feige revealed to Entertainment Weekly
that the concept is already coming together
nicely.
He said:
"One of the favorite pastimes at Marvel Studios
is sitting around on a Part One and talking
and dreaming about what we would do in a Part
Two.
There have been plenty of those conversations
as we were putting together the first Black
Panther.
We have ideas and a pretty solid direction
on where we want to head with the second one."
Writer/director Ryan Coogler is officially
on board, and while nothing is confirmed,
it's expected that the principal cast — including
Chadwick Boseman, Lupita Nyong'O and Danai
Gurira — will also return.
It's even been rumored that Michael B. Jordan's
Erik Killmonger could return in some capacity,
despite being left in no condition to do so
at the end of Black Panther.
In light of the megabucks that film made,
we're likely to get additional details on
this highly-anticipated sequel sooner rather
than later.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.